strike first strike hard no mercy
especially when it comes to netflix
copyright claiming everything we do but
i see they let some other people get
away with it anyway guys cobra kai
season four we got an actual trailer for
it it's called date announcement but uh
it's a minute long so there must be some
actual footage here worth checking out
obviously we have covered cobra cox he's
the one on the channel and cover kai
season three patreon john cover that by
himself over there but you best bet
we're going to be covering cover kite
season four i'm so
so
super excited for this maybe we'll see
some terry silver here oh we got to see
some terry got to see the terror that's
what everyone wants will give us the
terror give us that parrot
[Music]
many of us used to be enemies
but rivalries
don't need to last forever
tournament is just a few months away the
stakes are higher than they've ever been
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
it says back and forth
oh
silver
silver silver box over
[Music]
were here here we are living in the
twilight zone
december 31st again daily here last day
of the year happy new year you had to
crank them all out right away all right
that's right first of 2022 all the
reactions will be up wow you know what
uh kind of threw me for a loop what that
there was no hillary swank in this
trailer no hillary swing that's season
five john oh sorry um goodbye dang terry
silver
is
really old
he's an older fella he's got that silver
hair but he's still got the ponytail man
and he's still got the love for karate
because they brought them all back
you're right you know you got creased in
here you got johnny daddy and they're
all older yeah that was the first summer
i was like whoa you're really old
are you sure you need to be
right
i'm a little worried for you i know
you're supposed to be here to be
emotionally supporting crease don't go
to the hospital buddy like i don't know
anything about the actor terry silver
maybe for all i know he uh is the most
like well-trained the the biggest
martial arts enthusiast of them all and
he trains everybody for this show
i don't know anything about
them uh the the actor himself it's
exciting to have him back here and of
course like kicking off right from where
season three left off where they joined
forces and as we all expected there'd be
a clash of philosophies on their martial
arts approach and just right away like
you have like that inspirational moment
like here's how we're going to win this
is for all valleys right and immediately
they just start bantering and bickering
with one another i'm very excited to see
how they finally you know over the
course of the season they're gonna learn
how to teach together and i and i'm just
fascinated to know what ground danny
will give up and what grab johnny will
give up how johnny will get a little
more straight laced how danny will loose
it up a little bit this just looks like
so much fun like cobra kai always do i
mean yeah and like skimming this footage
here really quick i mean it looks like
there's like a homecoming or a problem
yeah would it be a prom for the seniors
yet i don't know
maybe this is like a homecoming or a
winter formal it's a sock hop a lot of
some kind of gym training and stuff in
there or dressed up in some fanciful
costumes or gymnasium at one point yeah
and it looks like danny and johnny are
gonna train each other at least by one
of these like there's danny climbing up
a chain with johnny and then the next
shot you've got johnny on the disc with
danny come on
i mean maybe perhaps that the key in
order to train their students is they
have to learn how to work with each
other first absolutely one another like
they have to really get that bond down
before trying to mentor the children
yeah danny's got to get a little tougher
and johnny has to learn a little bit of
that fluidity of miyagido yeah plus
there's that gymnastics shot i'm like
are they gonna start like branching out
from karate into like we just need
people who can like do a lot of flips
and confuse these yeah their opponents
or something like that or or am i
forgetting about a character with a
gymnastics background and johnny and
carmen are even gonna make up unless
this is a very misleading two frames of
them kissing well you know how marvel is
they like to cgi manipulate footage so
that's maybe danny's wife that's right
it's gonna be the conflict of season
five
i mean i'm excited for it cobra kai is
uh such a i'm glad that it got moved to
netflix because that's when i think it
truly started getting recognized for the
great show it is it had this like
resurgence and audience not only was it
a better platform for cobra kai to exist
but it also became like just much more
popular due to it being there oh yeah
and
and i feel like it's the best thing that
could have happened and now it's like i
think they have more plans past season
five like they said they're already
doing four and five
but i believe the show runners said like
we're actually hoping to keep it going
until season 10.
yeah
just more and more bring in more what
are they gonna do when they run out of
characters from the original canon
they'll start bringing in like extras
and supporting roles and like many
menial characters that don't really
actually add to the plot
um but i i have no idea how it's gonna
progress man i have no idea where this
is gonna go and i kind of love that yeah
man it's part of the excitement is that
mystery of like this already was like
such a long shot at the beginning and
then it worked so well the first time
and now it's worked so well for three
seasons you're like what are they gonna
throw to snap i just love how terry's
silver look all these people that's just
living the past yourself
even terry silver one
one movie
and he's always been dreaming of the
glory dude one movie and he's like i
gotta get back
to all valley i gotta show up like
michael myers to the cobra kai dojo
right here
stare down crease for a hot minute this
is so ridiculous but he's looking
fanciful i think he's got a ferragamo
belt on guy looks successful as hell uh
you should just do a whole fashion
breakdown on terry silver and i really
like this last bit too with amanda
because amanda was i didn't really grow
to love her like i've always liked her
but it was season three where i really
like grew to really appreciate her and
love her and she's so funny too i i
feel like
i'm a little concerned about the
relationship to be honest
i i think that is that could take a
dramatic turn this time around because
she is so supportive and you know you
see her drinking wine but i could see
her start to drink her her pain away
drink her sorrows away during all this
you know yeah could just be like ah
she's just gonna be a little bit
humorous sarcastic and then be that
cipher to point out how ridiculous all
this is and all that but at the same
time i am uh i'm a bit worried about the
relationship especially if her tension
with crease keeps escalating because
there is that shot of like her in the
grocery store and crease is like
standing right there and i mean they've
they've been building this like weird
rivalry between those two specifically
so part of me wonders like i feel like
it would almost be too big and broad and
silly but part of me is like what if we
got an amanda crease fight at some point
off and was just like train me i need to
kick this guy's ass
all right guys what'd you think of this
cobra kai trailer leave your thoughts
down below subscribe click that bell hit
that like button we'll catch you guys
soon
you